Let's say I have three position
vectors here in R2.
Let me scroll this over
a little bit.
Let's say my first position
vector is x0 and it is equal
to minus 2, minus 2.
So if I were to graph x0 I would
go minus 2, minus 2.
x0 looks like that.
My next position vector I have
is x1 and I'll say that's
equal to minus 2, 2.
If I were to graph
here, minus 2, 2.
That's my next position
vector right there.
And this is x1.
And when I say it's a position
vector, they specify a
specific coordinate in R2.
Let me draw a third one
just for fun, x2.
Let's say that that is
equal to 2, minus 2.
So if I were to draw this, 2
minus 2, it goes right here.
So that vector right
there is x2.
Now, what I'm curious
about or, I
guess, not curious about.
What I want to do here is define
the line segments that
connect these points.
So let's say I have my
first line segment.
Let me call it L1, or
let me call it L0.
And I want it to be the
line segment that
connects x0 to x1.
How can I construct that?
So I want to construct this line
segment right here, this
little-- let me do it in a
different color actually.
Let me do it in orange, L0.
So what I want to do is I want
to find the set of all of
these values right here, all of
the position vectors that
define points on this
line right there.
Well we could define it as,
we could start off at x0.
We could say that orange line is
x0 plus scaled versions of
the difference of x1 and x0.
If you take x1 minus x0, you get
this vector right there.
That's x1 minus x0.
That orange vector.
I know I wrote it right there
so it's hard to read.
But if you just take x1 minus x0
you get that and that make
sense. x0 plus this orange
vector is equal
to that blue factor.
So if you just take different
scaled up versions of this
guy, you're going to
end up at different
points in this direction.
We're starting at x0, maybe
I should do that in green.
We're starting at x0 and then
we're going to add up scaled
up versions of this orange
vector, which is just the
difference of x1 and x0.
Let me write that.
So scaled up versions
of x1 minus x0.
Now, we have to constrict.
If we just want to be in this
line segment, we have to
constrict Rt.
If we said t was a member of
real numbers, if it was any
real number, then we would
essentially be defining the
set of this entire vertical
line going up and down to
infinity in the upwards
direction and
the downwards direction.
But we just want to restrict
it to start here
and then go up here.
And it doesn't necessarily have
to have any direction.
We could say this is true, our
little line segment here is
true, for t-- let me
write it this way.
t is greater than
or equal to 0.
So when t equals 0, this term
cancels out and we just have
this point or this position
right here.
Let me draw it in green.
We just have that
position there.
And then t is going to be
less than or equal to 1.
What happens when
t is equal to 1?
When t is equal to 1, this
becomes x1 minus x0.
You have an x0 there.
This x0 and that x0 cancel out
and you're just at this point
right there.
When t is equal to 1/2, just
to make sure this all make
sense to you, what happens?
You have x1 minus x0, which is
this orange vector right here.
When t is equal to 1/2 you're
essentially scaling that
orange vector by half and you
end up right at that point,
which is exactly where
you want to be.
You want halfway along
that line segment.
At t is equal to 0.25, you're
going to be here.
t is equal to 0.75, you're
going to be there.
So at any value for t being any
real number between 0 and
1, you're going to end up at all
of the points along that
line segment.
So that's our L0.
It's just a set of vectors.
Now we can do the same exercise
if we wanted to find
out the line, the equation
of the line, that goes
between x1 and x2.
If we wanted to find the
equation of that line, we
could call this L1.
And L1 would be equal to x1 plus
t times x2 minus x1 for 0
is less than or equal to t is
less than or equal to 1.
That's L1.
And then finally, if we want
to make a triangle out of
this, let's define this
line right here.
Let's define that as L2.
L2 would be equal to the set
of all of vectors where you
start off at x2.
Set of all of vectors that are
x2 plus some scaled up sum of
x0 minus x2.
x0 minus x2 is this
vector right here.
So x0 minus x2 such that 0 is
less than or equal to t is
less than or equal to 1.
And so if you take the
combination, if you were to
define kind of a super set-- I
could have defined my shape
as-- let's say it's the union
of all of those guys.
Well, let me just write it.
L0, L1, and L2.
Then you'd have a nice
triangle here.
If you take the union of all of
these three sets, you get
that nice triangle there.
Now, what I want to do in this
video, I think this is all a
bit of review for you.
But it's maybe a different way
of looking at things than
we've done in the past. Is
I want to understand what
happens to this set right here
when I take a transformation,
a linear transformation,
of it?
So let me define a
transformation.
I'll make it a fairly
straightforward
transformation.
Let me define my transformation
of x, of any x,
to be equal to the matrix
1 minus 1, 2, 0 times
whatever vector x.
So times x1, x2.
And we know that any linear
transformation can actually be
written as a matrix
and vice versa.
So you might have said, hey,
you know, you're giving an
example with the matrix, what
about all those other ways to
write in your transformation?
You can write all of
those as a matrix.
So let's translate-- let's try
to figure out what this is
going to look like.
What our triangle is going to
look like when we transform
every point in it.
Let me take the transformation
first. The transformation of
L0 is equal to the
transformation of this thing.
This is just one of the
particular members.
For a particular t,
this is one of the
particular members of L0.
So it's going to be equal to the
transformation of x0 minus
the transformation of x1 minus
x0 such that-- sorry.
Minus t times x1 minus x0.
That's a lowercase t, not
the transformation.
Such that 0 is less than or
equal to t is less than or
equal to 1.
Let me switch colors.
This, just by the properties
of linear transformations,
this is equal to the
transformation-- let me put
the brackets out-- of x0 minus
the transformation of our
scalar t times x1 minus x0 for
all t's between 0 and 1.
That part is getting a little
redundant to keep saying it.
And then, what does
this equal to?
If you I take the transformation
of a scaled up
vector, that's just
the scaled up
transformation of that vector.
So this is going to be equal
to this part, the
transformation of x0 minus t,
our scalar multiple t, times
the transformation of the
vector x1 minus x0.
And then let me make sure I
get my parentheses right.
Such that 0 is less than or
equal to t is less than or
equal to 1.
And then the transformation of
the sum of two vectors is
equal to the sum of their
transformations.
We've all seen this before.
So our transformation of our
first line-- this one right
here-- L0, is equal to the set
where it's the transformation
of x0 minus t times the
transformation of x1 minus the
transformation of x0.
And we've just done our
first line so far.
I have a parentheses there.
For 0 is less than t is less
than or equal to 1.
Now this is a pretty neat
result and it's going to
simplify our lives a lot.
The transformation of the line
segment that goes from x0 to
x1 ends up just being the line
segment that goes from the
transformation of x0 to the
transformation of x1.
Let me make this clear.
What is the transformation
of x0?
Let's calculate these things.
So x0 was minus 2, minus 2.
Let me write out the
transformation of x0.
So the transformation of x0 is
equal to-- let me write it
out, so I don't make any
careless mistakes.
1, 2, minus 1, 0 times minus
2 minus, minus 2.
And so what would this
be equal to?
1 minus 2 minus-- so it's
1 minus 2 plus minus
1 times minus 2.
That's going to be plus 2.
So it's minus 2 plus a plus
2, so it's equal to 0.
And then we have 2 times minus
2, which is minus 4.
2 times minus 4.
And then plus 0 times,
so it's minus 4.
So that's the transformation
of x0.
Let me graph it.
So it's 0 minus 4.
So our x0 vector.
So this is the transformation
of x0.
So the transformation associated
this vector with
this vector down here, the one
that goes straight down.
Now let me take the
transformation
of the other guys.
The transformation of x1.
I'll just do it right here.
I'm running out of space.
The transformation of x1 is
equal to 1, 2, minus 1, 0
times minus 2, 2.
So what is this equal to?
This is equal to 1 times minus
2, plus minus 1 times 2.
So that's minus 4.
And then 2 times minus
2 is minus 4.
Plus 0.
So minus 4, minus 4.
So x1 is minus 4, minus 4.
So our x1 looks like this.
Our transformation of x1 is this
vector right here in R2.
Our transformation is
going from R2 to R2.
So that's why I'm able to draw
them both on this nice
Cartesian coordinate plane.
And we have one left.
Let's take our transformation
of x2.
So the transformation of x2 is
equal to our transformation
matrix 1, 2, minus 1,
0 times 2, minus 2.
And so this will be equal
to 1 times 2 is 2.
Plus minus 1 times minus 2.
So it's 2 plus 2 is 4.
And then have 2 times 2 is 4.
Plus 0 times minus 2.
So it's 4, 4.
So x2 is 4, 4.
So it's this point right here.
4, 4 right there.
So the transformation of x2 is
that vector right there.
And so, we are able to take the
transformation of each of
these points of this triangle.
But who knows what the
transformation does to
everything in between, to all
of these other-- the actual
sides of the triangle.
We're able to do a little
math and we just
did the first side.
We just did L0 right there
we found, just using the
properties of a linear
transformation, the definition
of a linear transformation
actually, we were able to find
that the transformation of L0 of
this vertical line here, it
just ends up becoming the line
where we can start off at the
transformation of x0.
The point specified by this
vector right here.
And to that I add up scaled
multiples of the
transformation of x1 minus
the transformation of x0.
What is this, the transformation
of x1 minus the
transformation of x0?
The transformation of x1 is just
this vector right here.
The transformation of x0
is just that vector.
So this whole term right here is
just this vector minus that
vectors or it's this
vector right there.
It's just that vector
right there.
And so, what we essentially
have, we've defined the same
way that we did in the first
part of this video.
This is just the same thing as
the line segment that connects
the point defined here and
the point defined there.
We took the difference of the
two and we have scaled up
versions of that between
t is equal to 0 and 1.
So the transformation of L0
really just became the
transformation-- is just
the line between the
transformations of both of the
endpoints, which is a pretty
neat result.
It makes our lives simple.
We can do the exact same logic
to say, you know what?
What's going to be the
transformation of L1?
Well L1 was between the
points x1 and x2.
It was between that point
and that point.
That was L1.
So using the same logic,
we can do the
math all over again.
But it applies to any line.
I did it all abstractly here.
The transformation of L1 is
going to be the line that
connects the transformation
of the two endpoints.
So it's going to be the
line that connects the
transformation of x1 and the
transformation of x2.
Let me make this right here, is
the transformation of L1.
This right here is the
transformation of L0.
And then finally, what's the
transformation of L2?
L2 connects the points
x2 and x0.
So that is L2 right there.
So the transformation of it
using the same math that we've
done before is really just
the line connecting the
transformations of
those two points.
So the transformation of L2 is
going to be equal to the line
that connects the transformation
of x2 to the
transformation of x0.
So it's going to be that
line right there.
So this is the transformation
of L2, or if we defined our
whole shape or our whole
triangle as the set of all of
these, the transformation
of that.
So the transformation of
our whole shape is
now this skewed triangle.
I think you're now getting a
sense of why this might be
useful in things like computer
graphics or game development.
Because when you look at things
from different angles,
you start to skew them
and whatever else.
But taking this transformation,
we were able
to turn this set of vectors or
the positions-- or I guess
this shape, which is specified
by this set of
vectors right here.
We were able to change it into
this shape in R2 specified by
a different set of vectors.
But the whole takeaway from this
video is, you don't have
to individually figure out,
gee, what does this point
right here translate
into over here?
All you have to say is what
were my endpoints?
Figure out their transformations
and then
connect the dots in
the same order.
That's what is essentially the
big takeaway from here.
And this idea of when you
transform one set into another
set, they have some terminology
associated with it.
So let's say the transformation
of L0.
L0 was the set of vectors
that specified
this line right here.
The transformation of L0, which
is this set, is a set of
vectors-- sorry.
L0 was this set.
It was the set of vectors in our
co-domain that specified
these points.
This is called the image
of L0 under T.
And it kind of makes sense.
Why do they call it the image?
Because t is taking this thing
right here, this L0, and kind
of distorting it or creating
a new image
of it in the co-domain.
It's taking a set in the domain
and creating a new
image of it in the co-domain
right there.
We could say that t of the
transformation of our entire
shape, I defined our entire
shape up here as this whole
triangle right there.
That's the image and that
turned into this purple
triangle here.
That's the image of s under T.
So hopefully you found that
pretty interesting.
This is actually a super useful
takeaway if you ever
want to become a 3D programmer
of some type.
In then next video, we'll
explore what happens when s is
no longer just a subset
of our domain.
Everything we've been dealing
so far-- L0, L1, and L2, or
our entire triangle, these
were all subsets or Rn.
In the next video we'll talk
about what happens when you
take the transformation
of all of Rn.